Rudy Giuliani is saying the quiet part out
loud after all this time spent arguing that
he's not involved in the Ukraine stuff, he
didn't interfere.
They didn't push anybody out.
Everything was perfect.
The phone call was perfect.
Their relationships with everybody over in
Ukraine, the ambassador at everybody else.
Everything was just perfect.
Rudy Giuliani has now admitted to new Yorker
reporter Adam entas that yes, he needed ambassador
Maria Bonovitch out of the way.
Later going last night on Fox news as Laura
Ingram Ingram program and saying, I got her
out.
You aren't supposed to admit this Rudy, but
you're certainly making it much easier.
That's for sure.
Quote from Adam entices great piece in the
new Yorker.
Rudy says, I believed that I needed you, Ivana
bitch out of the way.
She was going to make the investigations difficult
for everybody.
Rudy goes on to admit that he was working
on a dossier, not just about the Bidens, but
also about Marie Ivana, which herself and
said, let's make this as prominent as possible
by going on TV to talk about it.
Then last night, Rudy went on Fox news and
confirmed this to Laura Ingram.
Now he tries to deny that he needed her out
of the way, but admits that he forced her
out, which is exactly what they've been denying
all this time.
Take a look at this clip from last night.
Now this hit piece and it's a hit piece also
has you on the record admitting that you forced
out Marie Ivana, Mitch [inaudible].
You said you needed her out of the way, but
you're a personal attorney for the present.
So why do you need her out of the way?
I didn't need her out of the way.
I, I forced her out because she's corrupt.
So the alleged hit piece that Laura Ingram
is referencing is accurate.
And again, Rudy's trying to make this distinction,
I didn't need her out of the way.
I forced her out of the way.
The issue is a non-elected non Senate confirmed
nongovernment person who is Donald Trump's
personal lawyer forcing out ambassadors who
are, uh, selected by presidents.
This is red alert stuff.
And I know that in the era of scandal fatigue
in the era of constant drama and fiascos and
scandals, this stuff gets lost.
But Rudy Giuliani is admitting that he as
a non-government actor, saw an ambassador
as an impediment to getting what he wanted
and to Donald Trump getting what he wanted
and forced her out.
He admits it.
He's just a lawyer.
That's all.
He's not a government actor.
This is what they have been denying all along
during the impeachment hearings, one of the
main narratives that remember the Republican
lawyer during the impeachment hearings was
this guy Steve caster.
And what Steve caster tried to push was that
no one was trying to push Maria Bonovitch
out.
Everybody was fine with her being the ambassador.
Trump wasn't bothered.
Rudy wasn't bothered, but Trump wanted to
root out corruption and she didn't.
And all that stuff.
Here is Rudy admitting he says, uh, uh, to,
to Adam mentise.
She was an impediment and I needed her out
of the way.
He says, Laura Ingram, I got her out of the
way.
This is very reminiscent of when early in
Donald Trump's presidency, remember when they
were denying any contact with Russians is
laughable now because of everything we know.
But you had Trump denying contact with Russians.
Mike Pence was denying contact with Russians.
Don jr denied it.
Jeff sessions famously denied it when he got
caught lying and ended up having to recuse
himself on anything Russia related when he
was Trump's beleaguered attorney general.
Now it seems unbelievable that they were ever
denying it, but at one point they were, and
then you had Don jr tweet out, Oh yeah, we
were in touch with Russians, Russian business
people, this Russian, that Russian, but it's
no big deal and everything's fine.
It's denied, denied, deny until it's too late.
And then they don't, and then they say, well,
no, I mean, Oh yeah, it happened, but it's
totally fine.
Uh, the real story is some Democrat did some
other thing.
This time, I don't actually think it's part
of a plan by Rudy Giuliani.
It seems, once again, he's off the reservation
and this is exactly why Rudy Giuliani was
pulled off TV multiple times early this year,
very early this year.
We reported on it.
He blundered badly in multiple interviews
and he was pulled off for a while.
More recently he was pulled off again from
Fox news, but he did speak to this reporter
last month.
He then was back on Fox news last night and
it is as ridiculous as any of us imagined.
Everything is the opposite of what they tell
us.
Trump was rooting out corruption.
No Trump wanted smears.
You Bonovitch was working on corruption and
Rudy wanted her out and got her out even though
that's what they had been denying.
I really hope that Rudy Giuliani ends up testifying
in the Senate impeachment trial.
It would be something amazing to see people
around Trump should try to convince Trump
that it would be great for Rudy to testify
that Rudy would just do so great.
Of course it's not true, but that might get
Trump to tell Rudy to show up and testify
in the Senate impeachment trial and then it
would just be an amazing situation to watch.
Rudy Giuliani self-destruct.
Nevermind Trump.
Trump said he would consider testifying in
the impeachment trial.
I can't imagine he will be allowed anywhere
near the Senate trial by his lawyers to the
extent that they can control him, but we can
always hope and that would be, I mean instant
self-incrimination.
Let me know what your hoping for in the Senate
impeachment trial, given that a conviction
is extremely unlikely.
On January 1st we will be kicking off 2020.
It's insane that it's already 2020.
I remember when it was new year's Eve, 1999
and 2020 seemed comically far off and we're
just a couple of weeks from it.
On January one 2020, we will have a crazy,
uh, membership special if you've been thinking
of, it's an election year.
You want to support alternatives to corporate
media, get on our mailing list by signing
up for it@davidpakman.com subscribe the newsletter.
And then on January 1st you will get a beautiful
email.
A perfect email is Donald Trump would say,
uh, with an extremely extraordinary, uh, membership
special.
Let me know what you think about Rudy on Laura
Ingram by sending me a tweet at D Pacman.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this